في هذا الحي في ضاحيه نيه شخصين الثريه
يعيش النجم الارجنتيني ولاعب نادي باريس
سان جيرمان ليونيل ميسي في فيلا مؤلفه من
طابقين وبمساحه 300 متر اختار ميسي هذه
المنطقه من اجل مسائل تتعلق باطفاله
بالدرجه الاولى حيث توجد هنا مدارس
امريكيه واسبانيه تسهل على الاطفال متابعه
دراستهم بلغه يتقنونها لكن ايضا لان سكان
هنا اغنياء وهذا يجعل المدينه مقصدا
للمشاهير فهنا لا يستوقفهم احد لالتقاط
الصور في الشارع كان سكان اعتاد على رؤيه
نجوم الفن والكره وحتى السياسه والاهم من
ذلك ان ميسي لا يشعر بالوحده هنا لانه
محاط بزملاء له يسكنون في هذا الحي مثل
اخر ديماريه وماركو فيراتي
[موسيقى]
اماكن تختار النجم الفرنسي العيش هنا في
الدائره السادسه عشر الافخر على الاطلاق
في العاصمه باريس في شقه تقدر قيمتها بنحو
5 ملايين ونصف المليونير بيبي يستيقظ
صباحا على اطلاله يرى منها باريس وبرج
ايفل قبل ان ينضم الى زملائه
[موسيقى]
ميسي
سيكون اني خصمان في الدوحه عندما تلعب
الارجنتين ضد فرنسا لكنهما سيعودان للعب
معا هنا في باريس سان جيرمان وبحوزه
احدهما الكاس الاثمان كاس العالم
[موسيقى]